Here is a somewhat more formal definition from the definers of
the unified software process. I'm not going to recite it for you, but
I will mention several key elements. One is architecture is all about decisions,
choices that the architect makes about how which, which components are there,
how they interact, and how the non-functional requirements are being dealt with.
As far as the components are concerned, these are structural elements, and
they're interfaces, that is what they provide to the rest of the world, and
what they require from the rest of the world. Components interact, they,
they engage in collaboration with other components, and it is the composition of
these structural and behavioral elements into larger, and
larger subsystems that form the overall architecture. This structuring, this,
this composing may be guided by architectural styles, that provide guidance
as to or bring in experience that others have had with building similar systems.
The decisions about software architecture, concern not only the structure and
behavior but other important elements,
such as usage, performance, comprehensibility, understandability,
economics, technology constraints and trade-offs and aesthetic concerns.